some exciting news for secularists
atheists agnostics in Australia the
number of the the the top religious
classification in Australia is now quote
no religion we just got the results from
Australia's most recent census and for
the first time ever when people were
asked about the religious preference no
religion was the most popular response
we've got the results for you here and
as you'll see no religion thirty point
one percent of the Australian population
up about eight points since 2011
Catholicism second at twenty two point
six percent which is interesting because
a lot of people wrote to me Pat saying
you know a lot of those people saying
they're Catholic they are sort of
Catholic by birth but they're really
more non-religious they just call
themselves Catholic like secular Jews or
what sure same type of thing yeah not
surprisingly people aged 18 to 34 were
most likely to report no religion the
most religious state of Australia was
New South Wales where two-thirds of the
population reported a religious
affiliation and we still have a
plurality of Australians identifying
with a religion but we have the biggest
single response as no religion and of
course it can be a little deceptive
because Christianity is often split into
different denominations so right in
total if you combine all the Christians
and nominations that still is way bigger
than the number of people with no
religion but this is how people are
allowed to self-identify and and a
plurality now choosing no religion I
think it raises the question - if there
actually are more atheists in Australia
or if they're more willing to come out
so to speak because there's less of a
stigma behind not having a religion
that's another thing and a lot of this
is well do you still consider yourself
part of a religious group if you if your
parents are part of it even though you
don't really follow it that can skew
numbers it can also be skewed by what
Pat's pointing out which is you know the
it applies to the LGBT community as well
in order to understand if there has been
a change in the LGBTQ population you
also have to understand whether there
was honesty when people were polled
about that in
prior times when there was more stigma
attached to it Australia usually appears
in the top ten most non-religious
countries on earth in many polls that
includes countries like China Japan
Scandinavian countries and we also have
to remember how many agnostics and
genuinely non-religious people are still
a sort of identifying with a religion
but for cultural reasons and that's like
a very common thing in Judaism for
example where you will find totally
secular individuals who still
wholeheartedly identify as Jewish for
cultural or in the case of Judaism for
ethnic reasons so there's a lot of
caveats here but what's very clear is
that over the last 50 years the
percentage in Australia identifying as
non-religious is up thirty or forty X
and luckily Australia is in a much
better position when it comes to just
tolerance of atheism sure here in
America
most people people won't vote for an
atheist president more so than any other
reason right like you know if they were
Jewish or Muslim thank you for Allah
meanest right yeah even communist so
that's it that's a bad thing according
to Pew atheists in the United States are
the most stigmatized religious group
when Americans were asked to rate their
feelings about different religious
groups atheists were rated lowest which
is what Pat is pointing out what could
reverse the no religion trend in the
West I mean clearly as we are seeing the
advancement of science we have seen the
sort of a pullback of religion in most
Western countries we know that it's
science and progress and knowledge that
have caused that what could happen to
move people back towards religion I
think number one if quote God shows up
you'd see people move towards religion
but that would presumably be the god of
one religion showing up they can't all
be real so what would be the impact of
that I don't know I think maybe if we
learned a comment was coming to earth
and was going to wipe out civilization
definitively I feel like a lot of people
would would adhere to religion as a sort
of comfort I mean the holy idea behind
agnosticism and atheism is that we can't
prove that a God exists so therefore we
don't just arbitrarily believe in one if
Jesus himself comes down in the flesh I
think you'll see a lot of people convert
to Christianity right and you'll see a
lot of Christian any other prophet or
whatever we were right we were right
here's one other thing just to think
about overall the poorer you are the
more likely you are to be religious as
we've seen around the world when poverty
improves abject poverty really bad
poverty people tend to move away from
religion what about a major calamity
that pushes more people into poverty
that could also fuel increased
religiosity just thinking out loud send
me your thoughts on this I'm on Twitter
at D Pakman the show is on Twitter at
David Pakman show we've got a great
program for you today today's program is
made possible in part by taga dab the
hosting specialists they host websites
for everybody from bloggers to
businesses to financial traders you can
get virtual dedicated and private server
solutions cloud server solutions custom
server solutions whatever is right for
your project or business is available at
taga dab and with a growing number of
people increasingly interested in moving
their businesses and projects to the
cloud taga dab is offering our viewers
and listeners a twenty british pound
free credit when you sign up to give you
a chance to try out their cloud server
solutions this is a limited availability
offer first-come first-served for
viewers and listeners of the David
Pakman show
to take advantage go to signup tag
adhikam forward slash TDP s and use the
discount code TDPS
20 during your account registration 20
british pounds roughly twenty three
twenty four US dollars once again check
it out sign-up tag adapt calm /td PS the
discount code is TDPS
twenty